pas combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
papus il ne faut trop échos notez bien
sur vos droits au hasard
attention il en manque un
[Musique]
et
oh
est-ce qui va faire une bonne petite
sieste date ajoute est bon alors raconté
mon histoire
d'accord il était une fois en haut
possible
sachons au rouge la grand-mare loin
lanta lot c'est pas nouveau et
l'histoire d'un petit et ça donne à mes
pattes ajoute que les pâtes à puce avait
confié à la garde de monsieur bougon
finition et patata camp nou face comme
le match pendant seulement à mort à
trois enjeux question vous savez pas
d'autres histoires
je vais le calme et pour un bon moment
on va jouer à cache cache pas qu'en
basse à l'outil vous icône
je suis pas mal cachés ici mais les
marches arrières bourgon maria est pas
très pressé en ce qu'il ne sera pas de
me joindre un tour qu'est ce que c'est
que ce brigand aux flottes
[Musique]
chercheur au fait c'est quoi pour vous
être partie de moi je dérape à papa non
non non non non non non nous avons joué
ensemble pendant ce temps changent
points non aux indiens aux indiens et
aux visages pâles fait moins bien c'est
moins bien
oui oui et moi le visage pâle bon alors
20 verte habillé en indien maintenant je
suis bien tranquille
plus on n'en dira pas plus mais puis
l'aspect 120 je suis prof et et des
peintures de guerre pourtant c'est
indispensable pour un indien un peu de
rouge un pur de voir cet amas courage de
terre
[Musique]
ajaccio 1 fabrice joyeux non vie des
habitants je pense
mon parti